and here we have Magnus again with the
white pieces what's happening here oh
another Sicilian Defense and this time
maximum degrove is heading towards the
night off okay his specialty his
specialty uh one of everyone's favorite
openings I think uh of course favorite
of kaspara for Fisher some legendary
world champions and
okay oh the players repeated the moves
there just for a moment there is a
famous night off draw of White's Bishop
dropping back getting hit uh but of
course these players want to fight and
we're back towards the main line
slightly different Pawn structure Tanya
to the other night off but it's going to
be equally fighting uh then Magnus is
the one who goes for the night off and
Maxine says you can't do that against me
I'm the Knight of expert here so it is a
day of the open Sicilian and I'm loving
it already
I think we'll learn a lot from this game
in terms of where to put your pieces for
both sides in this type of structure
black is super flexible and I would
argue that black is much more flexible
in this kind of branch of the night off
than Magnus was in the previous game uh
where we saw him fix the center very
early on and uh are you surprised Tanya
because if Magnus plays one E4 he's
hoping for the Sicilian Idol surely yeah
he is but Maxim's not one that afraid
this is an opening that Maxim has played
all his life against the very best
players in the world so it doesn't
matter who he's playing how well they're
prepared Maxime really knows all the ins
and outs of this opening so it's going
to be quite an interesting middle game
battle what does Magnus have in mind
against Maxim's night off for now Maxim
stops any advance on the king side the G
Pawn has been stalled you really don't
want to pick up the B4 Pawn as white
right now you could end up facing big
troubles if you're inaccurate Magnus
decides to go for long Castle
immediately and now for maxim does he
continue with development improving uh
the bishop he starts with improving his
Knight brings it on to E5
branch of the Sicilian named after
Argentinian Grandmaster Miguel neidor
fits competitive it's a favorite of
several world champions and it's not a
coincidence black has such a flexible
position you keep all the pieces on the
board it's so Dynamic and that's all you
need when you want to outplay your
opponents did you ever delve into the
night off yourself with black yes but
not very successfully I quickly gave up
that experiment Tanya and it goes again
he does it yeah it goes against what
we're taught opening the position when
your opponent's king uh is slightly
safer when your king is sitting in the
middle uncastled but he does it I think
he's ready because Pawn takes porn here
would be met by a night jump and these
two black knights just control
everything
threatening to take maybe threatening to
jump into a nice hole in the opponent's
camp
I think Magnus here has to be really
careful how he Treads he does attack
this Black Knight very logical and if
the Black Knight moves maybe he's aiming
to block up the center and uh Black's
own Bishop on D7 very often it can
actually move to B5 offering a trade
even at the cost of the pawn it has to
be timed really well obviously not right
now but to open up the airline so there
are these ideas that exist what on Earth
just happened vasilograph has sacrificed
a piece out of the blue totally
unexpected let's do a quick action
replay his Knight was attacked
more positional players more
conservative players would have
retreated their Knight but he jumps in
gives up a whole piece and he lands
another night in the center of the board
it's a piece for two porn sacrifice he's
only sacrificed one point but this
Knight is gonna jump into some nice
squares David he goes with a similar
idea to F6 defending the G7 Pawn but in
a different way he lines it up with the
rook and Bishop C5 is coming next WoW
Magnus jumps forward I was going to say
to jump to
in order to try and get his Bishop on
the long diagonal really promising
diagonal but okay Magnus does not allow
this he first jumps in with his Knight
and what is the idea he's got something
up his sleeve surely to meet Bishop C5
in this White Queen
what is it he only has one safe square
if he drops back the Black Knight might
come and start forking
maybe it's this queen to H7 hitting the
undefended Rook Magnus is seen deeper
yeah there we go it's on the board
Magnus will he Retreat his queen as
we're expecting the fact paused Queen
sacrifice
Magnus Carlson surprising us not
retreating to a passive Square gives up
his Queen and then Maxine gives the
queen straight back that was crazy Let's
do an action replay because the dust has
settled now but uh I mean the players
they're so good they're another level
they saw all of that and it wasn't
obvious at all uh the queen retreating
to D3 was the move we expected the only
safe square but Magnus of course
surprised us Queen takes Knight giving
up his Queen for two pieces Knight takes
D7 now so he's got a bishop and a knight
for that Queen all sorts of threats such
as hitting this bishop Maxim did not
even hesitate giving the queen back for
the night and a rook this time let's do
some counting on a beautiful Square
beautiful Outpost trying to come in what
is next for white
it's a mystery for example we could
maybe just see a trade and the White
Knight come forward here we would see a
weird material imbalance of Queen for
three pieces uh black has a queen white
has a knight and two Bishops so again
nine for nine there pretty much but it's
all about the activity of the pieces
maybe he was just terrified that the
White Knight would come in and uh the
black king is still not entirely safe so
instead of this material and balance he
goes for a different one where he's
actually material up pinky is actively
using breathing I know a lot of players
do um a good cash I think meditates Eric
icy with it yeah I think he just really
brings out it brings out their ability
to control themselves and to calm
themselves down and just really the best
in them and that's why they're Champions
yeah and they probably enjoy it as well
right when it is fire on the board I was
actually gonna ask right before Magnus
sacrificed his Queen if it was sort of
giving Maxim and Edge that he had
sacrificed a piece because well if I
lose this game then at least I played
Something Beautiful is it a mind game by
Magnus then to sacrifice himself himself
so he sort of gets
you know levels the the Mind Games again
what's happening on the board if they
feel like that's the best alternative
that's the best option so concrete just
calculated till the end neither of these
player wants to go into a passive
position wants to defend long term so
they always go for these combative
options for 40 moves and then you make
one inaccuracy and it all just goes down
the drain none of it really matters and
it's heartbreaking and nobody cares
about how beautiful the game was and
this one will it be a winner in this
game or will we have a third drawer what
do you think with this material
imbalance a draw seems least likely
right now I'm not sure I mean the
evaluation bus slightly prefers white
but I'm not sure in Practical terms
whose position is easier to play White
has the two Bishops which usually
triumph over a rook but look at that
massive black pawns on the king side
what is doing a good job right now
Magnus is kind of prioritizing
blockading then the tables could turn so
it's not clear what next I really like
what Maxine's been doing he's just kind
of sitting on the position right now and
uh he's making it hard for watching
proof we have Bishop 86 on the board by
the way I
think it runs into Bishop G5
you check and uh this bishop of course
can be taken but the white Rook can now
capture the black Rook on h8 with
impunity the problem is maybe this black
pawn is starting to roll I mean this is
such a crazy position how is the
evaluation bar still almost in the
center why is the bishop up
I don't understand but uh maybe these
pawns are running he's reaching out but
if not Rook to h8 then white just
anywhere falls back with the bishop
activating his own rook and Maxim does
go for counter-attack against the other
Bishop on E2 we'll defend it but uh the
bishop gains time against blackstroke so
we'll go back blackstroke has to watch
out right because you want to stay
connected to that G5 square that you
pointed out earlier Bishop G5 is also a
threat in the position so expecting
Maxim to move the Rook along the G line
somewhere three or four safe squares he
drops back hitting the white Bishop uh
so those two pawns keep the white
Bishops tied down to the defense of them
rolling forward the Magnus he's jumping
around shuffling around with the bishop
first threatening a check on one side
and now entering from the other side
Bishop C5 in the air The Rook jumping on
to eight seven joining the attack there
can be fire against Black's King even
though there's such few material on the
board
the two Bishops are great attacking
yeah
at meeting that around the black king
potentially let's just show that type of
idea if Maxime is careless of course he
won't be but if he just plays oh Magnus
reacts here oh maybe he's missed
something if Maxine would just make a
random move let's say he repeats then
the white Rook could come in and behind
and okay uh the valuation bar reacts but
this would have been a mating pattern uh
at least black now entering the center
whoops my arrows are crazy today but uh
Pawn to F4 in the air still not
immediately a threat but white goes
behind so if you go F4 you give a check
the King has to fall back and then the
F4 Pawn but he goes for F4 whoa this
would be a trick Bishop takes F4 now
would be losing Tanya because look at
this Suddenly It's black who's mating
the white king
oh my God this is a deadly trick a
really really dastardly trap here I
missed something that is uh the key now
for Magnus and he does give this check
but if he takes this Pawn he'll lose he
doesn't take the uh the bait there and
he finds the best move gaining time
against blacks Rook
that that being said black spawns are
pretty impressive right now so if black
can survive the next few moves and get
them rolling then Maxim still has a
chance and
the black Rook Rook D7 you can ask more
questions Bishop to B5 it's just not so
easy for the Rooks to feel comfortable
once the bishop stopped coming after
them but he takes a pawn but doesn't
this allow oh when the evaluation bar is
getting confused here the black pawns
are rolling I think there was no mating
net there because white would have
eliminated the remaining black pawn the
pawn on B4 and whites king would have
had some breathing space so Maxim he's
going all in he's thrown all of his
chips behind his uh pawns here in the
center and they're rolling but it's the
black King David that there can be a
mating net with the two Bishops and The
Rook uh trying to line up against
Black's King but I'm not seeing it the
good thing for Magnus is these pawns
they're rolling but he can give up one
of his Bishops for them and he should be
relatively safe there he plays the most
natural check but the evaluation Bar
says no how frustrating is this the
black king has only got two safe squares
it gains time against the white Rook and
now does Maxi make a new Queen no he
doesn't
crazy move here don't take this Black
Brook black will make a new Queen uh
this Rook is poisoned and the other
black pawn is Gonna Roll I love that
move by Maxima just offering his Rook
you can't take it and as you said it
defends the e-pawn uh wanting to go E6
next and the bar is just going crazy
there's a bit of yo-yo going on and
nobody knows what's happening yeah yo yo
YOLO it's just one of those games one of
those positions in Tanya I'm just going
to jump in very quickly to point out a
crazy tactic that maximum actually
missed just a few turns ago here he
played Rook to E1 a move we really like
defending this Pawn he could have played
the insane Rook to D3 this isn't me
don't worry it's the computer route to
D3 and black makes a new Queen you
simply give up your Rook to cut the
connection with the bishop and this
promotion Square watch out for this to
arise later
um the evaluation Bar says still
complicated but
um yeah it's just that type of position
tricks all over the shop
that's stunning Rook D3 uh what a move
but you can't fault Maxim for not
finding uh that one and now Magnus lines
it up against the F2 Pawn black can
start advancing the E Pawn that's just
no easy moves oh black oh is that a
blunder makes a blender but why is this
a mistake it looks very natural trying
to eliminate one of White's Bishops the
Bishops are the only pieces that stop
Black's pawns looks like a very logical
move to me
but maybe this is the refutation it's so
nice because it's all about the
Intermezzo if you take that bishop and
C4 white will not recapture The Rook but
go Bishop takes E3 with a check key
moment he has to give away his Bishop
take a pawn with check and look at
maximum degrath suddenly hand on his
face he tries to keep a poker face but
he missed this one and here we go white
simply takes that black Rook whites Rook
remember Rooks behind past pawns they
control everything and suddenly magnus's
Queen side pawns will run black is too
slow in this race and Maxime knows it he
looks away it has been an up and down
roller coaster game but I think the ride
is coming to an end now for Maxine with
the F Pawn stopped by The Rook uh
nobody's gonna stop the pawns on the
queen side and Magnus there's shaking
his head and Magnus takes the win Maxine
resigns wow we have the first decided
game and the winner is final Magnus
takes the win